uh do i go full tilt
and play a stafford
or england
or just win on time before my opponent
moves
oh opponents berserking
yeah this is how you berserk on
chess.com
there's no berserk button so you just
have to
wait
a lot of time before making your first
move
i'm insisting on stafford
uh there's two moves here there's d5 and
castling
oh castle
94
so d6 there's f6
i think d6 makes sense bishop g4
i'm still down the pawn but i have the
bishop here i'm castled
there's gonna be pressure
i mean white's still probably
objectively better
you now bishop b4
or bishop g4
so bishop c2 okay queenside castling
makes a lot of sense
and take some queen e7
yeah two attackers knights pinned
i mean there's rookie one rookie eight
mb5
maybe rook d8
controlled open file
yeah the point is now to take
and knight d4
i'm getting some play here
queen g5
could be a move b5 is a move
actually b5 c5
might as well push the pawns on the
queen side
go for some attack
this b b4 could strike
and it forces files to open up
okay
huh
i want to do things but
not so simple
c4
c4 we trade
[Music]
yeah it's another pawn sacrifice
rook g1 i
probably playing out of five
like b3 incoming
not super sound but it's interesting
actually wondering if i can take on a3
here
some g7 move
maybe just g6
no g6 doesn't defend though
three
play b3 and pray
wow
i really want to take on a3
please let me do it please play queen f6
let's go is it i don't know if it works
so it looks so funny
oh no my queen
if takes like pawn mate b2 checkmate
queen here doesn't help rook takes g6
doesn't help
and i'm threatening one
i don't see the defense for white
what a finish
hey it's benjamin bach
oh you're waiting in a nice time look at
this finish
i was down a piece
but we have a uh a pond
duel and
the final move of the game queen jake's
a3
and white just has no defense
oh no my queen
shout out to bach
hope you had a good stream
frozen's alive
yeah i feel more alive after this game i
was feeling kind of dead
it hasn't been the best tournament
but this move makes me more alive
as a force mates it might be force mates
engine
oh queen d6
queen g6 only way to
basically prolong the game
[Music]
oh do game review yeah it better give me
uh
at least two exclamation marks
if not more
we need to make a new symbol
[Music]
to make more exclamation marks
where is it
a
why does this not show the the symbol
it shows it here it usually shows it on
the board though
[Music]
gonna have to do some photoshop for the
youtube thumbnail